[Musique]
moi je vous dis
que nous allons accéder en l'occurrence
à l'elysée avec les français les
électeurs de avait fait appel à tous les
électeurs madame ventura tous car encore
une fois ce que je souhaite c'est faire
un gouvernement d'union nationale
vous a plu au rassemblement alors j'ai
vu la liste eric zemmour bruno
retailleau marine le pen florian
philippot julien aubert je donne la
liste soit xavier bel ami michel onfray
philippe de villiers qu'on a eue ce
week-end c'est le pire de la politique
c'est un spectacle absolument déplorable
c'est ce qu'on aime le moi je crois en
politique ce n'est pas les convictions
c'est la manoeuvre politicienne les
combinaisons d'arrière cuisine
nous aurons certainement pas on se parle
pas comme ça d'abord la meilleure
solution ce serait c'est un rêve mais
parfois les rêves deviennent réalité
ce serait que nos électeurs les millions
d'électeurs qui veulent l'alternance qui
veulent même plus que l'alternance
l'alternative est bien choisir leur
champion et si c'est marine le pen je
m'inclinerai si c'est bruno retailleau
je m'inclinerai si c'est moi je leur
demande aux cimaises de s'incliner
mais si si si vous parliez à tour de
rôle se soit pas apathique
non non non aucune division et aucune
division
non aucune on apprend grâce à vos quand
certains de vos confrères parisiens que
en réalité la liste des noms a même été
donnée par l'elysée et on voit que
finalement tout ce qu'il avait dit n'est
pas respectée ce n'est pas le premier
ministre qui décide pour moi c'est pas
le président de la république ici pour
moi c'est pas ma formation politique
issue pour moi je suis un homme libre et
je le fais avec
avec mes amis dans le cadre de mon
travail que j'ai toujours fait au sein
de ma famille que tout le monde
reconnaît moi j'ai jamais trahi monsieur
maintenant que la république en marche
ne figurera pas au moins les poids
lourds du parti présidentiel sur les
listes de renaud muselier est bien est
ce que le parti présidentiel soutient
toujours le président ait l'air de la
région paca
rien n'est moins sûr réponse dans les
prochains jours image d'un pont du métro
il s'est effondré au moment du passage
d'une rame en plein coeur de
de mexico il y avait beaucoup de monde
dans les rames évidemment mais aussi en
voiture file et melinda gates divorce
après 27 ans de mariage le milliardaire
quatrième fortune mondiale et sa femme
annonce cependant qu'ils vont continuer
à travailler ensemble au sein de leurs
fondations
les raisons de l'accident ne sont pas
encore connus mais les médias locaux
évoquent tant défaut de la structure
très fragilisés par le tremblement de
terre de 2010 est la télévision
mexicaine pointé du doigt exactement ce
même lieu fragilisé après un séisme
sur ces images ou une rame de métro se
trouve sur le pont aujourd'hui effondré
on constate que la structure était déjà
fléchi tordu prêt à céder on est aux
alentours d'une baisse de 20 % peut-être
un petit peu plus d'un pour cent d'une
semaine sur l'autre du nombre de
nouveaux cas donc on devrait bientôt
franchir la barre des 20000 cas par jour
ce qui reste un niveau élevé de
contamination donc les français qui nous
écoutent ne doivent pas considérer
qu'ils sont hors de danger et que
l'épidémie est terminée
la scène se déroule avenue de flandre en
plein paris des tirs de mortiers qui
ciblent des toxicomanes les auteurs
seraient les riverains eux mêmes
excédés par les nuisances pour le mans
le dernier tabou c'est l'utilisation des
armes à feu contre les forces de
sécurité intérieure et entre habitants
du quartier sauf parce que là ça existe
déjà on l'a vu à valence entre bandes
le monde compte entre voyous il est 17h
ce dimanche dans le quartier de la
duchère deux jeunes à scooter et sans
casque percute une femme avant de
prendre la fuite
transportée à l'hôpital la victime n'est
que légèrement blessé
donner à ce monument une nouvelle vie un
défi pour près de 20 millions d'euros
tout en bois modulable ce plancher va
être réalisée par une entreprise de
milan la marine britannique elle a
réalisé un test de jet soute
ces engins là vous voyez volant tests
avec des militaires est 2023 des
spectacles pourraient même s'y dérouler
une véritable renaissance